we recently played the overwatch 2
closed alpha and today we're going to
talk about whether or not it feels like
the fully fledged sequel that blizzard
hopes it does or whether or not it feels
just kind of like overwatch 1.5 i'm lucy
james and i am joined today by tim
hussein hello
and our very special guest style oso
hello hello hello
for people who don't know you start
loser yes okay well if you google
stylose you'll probably see about 4 000
or maybe even 5 000 videos on overwatch
i have made a lot of content on
overwatch over the years
that's me
one of the kings party praise high
praise
no pressure um but the three of us we
were recently in the closed overwatch
two alpha which is basically we got to
play it for it was open for a good
couple weeks uh we all got a bunch of
time in it it was all the pvp none of
the pve stuff um so the new maps the new
mode the new hero was all there
and uh
it was an interesting interesting time
um
let's start with kind of
very very broad and we'll we'll talk
about everything kind of individually in
a sec but like what are your broad
impressions styles are going first so
the game is faster um there's a lot more
onus on individual performance now than
than the was in 6v6 um
it kind of plays in
it feels weird to begin with because
it's almost like a tank is disconnected
from each team and you're like what's
going on here like why have i only got a
ball as my tank or a roadhog it feels
really strange um but yeah it's faster
as i said there's more onus on skill
even if you look at sojourn the the new
hero
her ultimate when she overclocks a
railgun
you have to land those shots if you
don't
then you suffer and it's always been
like a
a niggly pointless with the overwatch
community the balance between like
heroes that have almost got like
uh how can i say this diplomatic like i
win buttons or that they're maybe lower
skill level compared to heroes that
require a lot more mechanical skill so
yeah it's faster that's that's the
biggest takeaway from this is definitely
faster and it
still feels like overwatch kind of
you've just got one less
tank yeah and i mean to that point about
um being more skill based it also kind
of to me it felt like there was more
pressure on role selection because
you feel more pressured to be useful
and i'm really interested to see when
this goes live and it goes wide to see
if there are gonna still be those people
who are like well screw you guys i'm
gonna pick a hero that's gonna be
completely
unhelpful but i'm gonna go and just get
you know try and get as many kills as
possible um tam what were your
impressions yeah i i very very similar i
feel like it felt very familiar and
the other part of it was um like celos
has said it feels a lot more skill based
and
i don't know it it kind of felt like
there was a lot more pressure because of
it which i i think is going to be
interesting because
the i think overwatch 2 success came
from being able to appeal to a lot of
people and being able to find a groove
for you regardless of your skill level
like you could play a mercy or you could
play a another character that you know
for again using the similar terminology
has an i win button or is at least a
character that can kind of fall back and
and serve a function without getting
into the thick of it um and the two
tanks kind of
helped in that
in a lot of ways now i feel like
everyone needs to everyone's kind of a
bit more exposed everyone is a little
more on edge and a lot a little more is
expected of each player which i don't
know how that's going to translate into
performance for the game overall
i suspect it might be a situation where
a certain group of people think oh
overwatch too that's the approachable
multiplayer competitive game they jump
in and just are getting wiped at like
how quickly everything moves and how
much like more punishing small mistakes
or out of place moves are um it's still
an exciting game to play in a lot of
ways but it's also still very much that
game that feels a bit different and is a
little more like um kind of uh
edge of the seat am i doing something
wrong am i screwing things up for the
team feeling
yeah and i mean two on top of that i
guess to kind of try and mitigate that
they've incorporated a ping
which i
barely used i don't know about you too
so yeah the ping system is weird so i
think that there could be some issues
with ping where it might be optimal to
ping everything all the time everybody's
constantly pinging and that's the way
you should use it um
i think in regions like if you look at
europe and there's a lot of different
languages so ping actually can be quite
good in that regard but it's um
something i would have liked to have
seen in overwatch two years ago you know
what i mean it's like yeah it's fine
it's great you know we've all played
with apex legends ping system and
valorum and all of that stuff so
yeah it's nice yeah it feels kind of
a little out of place here given how
kind of controlled the environment is
like the ping system works in battle
royale games because you have this open
environment and you have many different
areas or kind of angles of approach
whereas in overwatch
chances are the angles of approach are
quite limited like you have a a lot of
sight lines but there are limited number
of sight lines and if you're a good
player you're always checking those
sight lines so
pinging feels like if it's kind of like
a whole lot
from what we've seen so it's basically
used to ping if somebody is flanking
that's it because when you're playing
like if you're pinging targets in front
of you everyone can see that um
i don't think we're really going to see
people pinging to say hey let's set up
here for an attack because the game well
you guys have played you know what it's
like it's so like it's like a big brawl
now everyone says it's death matchy and
it really is it's like a massive fight
but for pinging or there's a tracer
behind yeah it's actually really good
for that
yeah it is it is good for that provided
that you're not using voice comms
because yeah yeah yeah
if you're on voice comms it's literally
easier to hear the tracer behind you and
go hey there's a tracer behind us i
heard it yeah it feels like a it's
something that's going to be useful in a
limited um kind of context if you're
playing you know with people randalls uh
just pick up games or something like
that and just to kind of signal where an
enemy or even like hey i'm going here
like cello also said it feels like it
should have been here two years ago yeah
it's like a little incremental upgrade
it's like it's just little it's fine but
it's just a little thing let's talk
about the new hero because she was
finally playable so i i would say that i
am typically more of a tank uh support
player um dps
not really my thing i did mess around
with um sojourn a little bit and i liked
the way she felt to play um and i mean
we talked about apex a little bit the
fact that she has that slide
just it felt really good
but if i think if i was going to be
picking a dps hero a damage hero i would
still opt for soldier over her i mean
like let me go through her um her
abilities so she's got a rail gun with a
primary and alt-fire the alt-fire you
kind of have to charge the the railgun
by hitting hitting shots uh she's got
the power slide that you can cancel out
into a big jump uh disrupter shot which
is um
kind of like a
mini sort of sorry you know it's it's um
fairly big area of effect damage but it
slows you down which is really weird
because blizzard did say they wanted to
remove um slows and stuns off dps heroes
there you go
no i mean maybe maybe they met like but
after this you know we just want to get
this one out the door and then after
they have said the reason why sojun has
it is so it makes lining up the railgun
shots easier but
i don't think it helps that much yeah
and then and then uh her ultimate is
overclock where the railgun is uh the
alt-fire is just is constantly pretty
much um powered up i liked her she's
she's not in my particular kind of
wheelhouse in terms of characters that i
like to play um so i'll say i'll go to
youtube what did you think of her i it
was really interesting the slide was it
feels a lot like the ping where it is
something that
it feels almost
obliged they were like obligated to put
it in based on the context we're doing
there because the slide is good but then
very quickly i felt like i was trying to
sprint in a shoe box where it's like you
start sliding and then it's like oh you
you're hitting a wall or you know you're
in between the payload and the other
thing the slide felt like a good way to
like get in and out of stuff i guess but
like the best utility for me i found was
like immediately using it to super jump
into the air and get like good
positioning in the air um it is
effectively in terms of what utility i
was using as is like the the widow uh
grapple jump to try and get into the air
and then obviously when i'm in the air
i'm absolutely useless at landing shots
in the air it looks good i'm sure
but like so i was just like leaping into
the air and just getting shot out of
this guy constantly
by pros to be fair because we were
playing with like our players so i was
like i guess i could see why this is
here and it kind of fits
she feels like i feel like i she doesn't
work for me but i feel like if we
watching a pro play her it's going to be
like incredibly exciting because she's
like leaping into the air and there were
a couple of times where it was like oh
the the enemy team is like engaged in a
skirmish and they're not paying
attention to me and i could like launch
myself over them and behind them yeah
but then once i got behind them it was
up to my you know skill based shots to
i needed to basically headshot headshot
headshot pick him off and i wasn't doing
that i was landing behind him and being
like ah
help me she's like i wasn't using it it
made me a liability
she's like easy to get into position but
then difficult to execute that's the
problem with sojourn the soldier example
is actually really good because soldier
is very powerful in in this world
because
we there's only one tank and if it's not
a diva tac visor ultimate is free that
is a an iwin button you press that and
you just kill everyone you compare
attack visors to sojourn's uh overclock
well you have to aim overclock so it's a
bit more difficult to land the shots so
i've enjoyed playing it
the
the movement you can chase people down
with it you can disengage really fast
with it as well um it is very good for
accessing high ground which again makes
a you know a little bit better than
soldier in that regard because he's
always going to be the one you compare
sojourn to in my mind because if you've
got the aim you play sojourn
if you've got no brain like me you just
play soldier because you know you're
going to get attack visor and you know
you're going to be able to kill them all
with it um but yeah she she's a really
cool hero the disrupter shot kind of was
a bit weird to me because i don't even i
don't really get why that's part of a
kit because if she's based around high
mobility and she's based around highly
accurate shots then to just suddenly
give her this like aoe
damage over time
ball that also slightly slows people
down seemed a little bit weird um yeah
but the the most interesting thing about
the whole hero to me is the fact her
ultimate is is a skill based ultimate it
is not just i pop this and i kill the
enemy team you can pop it and believe
you me i've got loads of clips of me
popping this ultimate and doing nothing
and i'm like oh god this is terrible and
like you guys said when we were playing
against overwatch league pros they'd pop
it and they'd kill everyone and you're
like oh my god this just look what's
going on this is broken well
those guys can aim but if if you've got
a diva
and divas on top of the soldier and then
the sojourn finds it really hard to fire
the railgun because the diver eats the
railgun so there's all these little
interactions but
that kind of goes back to the point you
guys made earlier about more pressure
being on you uh when you play this game
um the tank roll there's only one tank
but it's so um or it seems to be very
rock paper scissors and balanced now
like extremely so if your tank count is
the enemy's tank you almost win those
fights all the time and the same you
know goes for dps and supports and
supports get a they've got a bit of a
rough time at the moment because they're
um living in a world where
they're quite vulnerable the one thing
like as someone who plays a lot of um a
lot of support the fact that everyone
now auto heals over time great thank you
as you know i mean not very quickly i'll
admit but you know the fact that
not fast enough but as an anna you know
the fact that i'm not having to waste my
my grenade to heal myself or like
disengaging just because i'm you know
one hp away but a bunch of the other
characters also got like slight tweaks
cassidy now has like a
what is it like a
yeah it's a magnetic grenade yeah
grenades cassidy is an interesting one
so his
fan the hammer is 18 faster which is
fairly good against tanks um but his
magnetic grenade so he can throw this
and it's got a 10 meter range these are
all alpha figures they might change but
it it will magnetically attach to a
target and it'll explode on them and i
think it does about 120 130 damage but
what's interesting about it if you look
at the um
cassidy tracer match up in the past
if you flash the tracer and you can aim
you'll probably kill that tracer but now
you throw the magnetic grenade
it'll attach to the tracer but if she's
got rewind then she can rewind away so
she can actually it's easier for tracer
to deal with cassidy you know which so
it's these like little weird like
interactions going on um but i think
it's fun i think cassidy's change is
actually quite fun especially throwing
it at mercy when she's trying to res
someone watching it connect
it's really good
um and then i mean but we talk about the
other heroes who have had kind of more
significant reworks so
is now a tank
i
don't actually play a lot of doomfist
and i i gave him like a little whirl and
i was like he feels weird he's got like
a little thing where he can shield now
orisa's rework i really liked um and
bastion too um
so i guess we'll go through them i mean
would you make a what do you make a doom
tam did you play doom i don't i have a
an intense dislike of doomfist and it's
just i i've always fought dooms and
dooms behave in the same ways uppercut
pounce
get away and it's like i hate you guys
so much so like every time i see a doom
now i'm like i'm staying away from me so
i don't know what's going on with that
character i i hope that it makes i i'm
able to kill him a lot more now so it's
actually a really good change on
blizzard's part because the play style
is the same he is just now a tank so
all of those dps doomfist players out
there they will just pick doomfist and
they can still play him how how he
functioned um on the live services dps
but
he's very he's very feast or famine doom
is he goes in and he either does
something or he dies or
he gets out and he's achieved nothing
and then he repeats the process over and
over again it's always interesting
talking about doom because we've got
wrecking ball and wrecking ball in a lot
of ways is a better doomfist in this
overwatch two world
and paul winston is is just not very
good at all
yeah
that's the thing and when we're talking
about the fact that you know you're
losing
a tank i i when i was playing i was like
i don't see why you would ever pick
winston anymore
like he's just with one tank i don't see
why you would pick winston winston they
gave him the little alternate fire so he
can charge up his weapon it fires a
little
it doesn't do a lot of damage but you
have to like
it's forgetting people as they're
running away from you right but what's
weird with winston is obviously the the
meme with winston is um you know you've
got no aim so you play winston and all
that stuff um what's it no aim no brain
i'm a winston maine something like that
but then if someone's trying to escape
then suddenly you need to have aim to
shoot at them with this and then you
miss and it's like oh this i should have
just chased them you know it's it's not
a very good um like mini rework on
winston but he just suffers because all
of the other tanks with mobility are
better than winston so i don't know why
you'd pick winston
but i mean orisa's had more of a
significant rework i i really like the
arisa changes because uh so they got rid
of um her shield her deployable shield
and um oh my god yeah
shield watch is over and now she she
kind of her all fire was like a javelin
throw which does a little bit more
damage if you it kind of knocks someone
into a wall um she also has this move
where she spins her javelin like moves
forward and uh
the uh kind of knocks back projectiles
and kind of pushes into into um the
enemy and i i really enjoyed her rework
her her alt is now what like a yeah it's
a hero
yeah so she basically she applies
fortified herself so she can becomes
really tanky um she throws a spear up in
the air and it creates like a big area
around her that sucks people in and the
longer you wait the more damage it will
do because you can like cancel the
ability um so you can use it to pull
people out of position and then slam
them so i think what they're looking for
players to do is use the
the javelin spin because that's got i
think that's got a 60 movement speed
buff pop that run into them and then use
your ultimate drag them towards you and
then sort of blow them off it feels cool
to do it i don't know how like
balanced this is or if it's any good but
it just feels cool running into them
because finally erisa you know she's got
four legs she can run in so it's like
this feels good finally the horse
the horse is finally realized
um but no i mean i really enjoyed her
changes and bastion as well is one of
those ones where i put i i feel like i
never play bastion just because i
remember the early days of overwatch
where i was like oh you're playing
bastion oh okay
like if you talk about characters with
the
with the wizards a lot of stigma
um especially when you were allowed to
have duplicates of heroes but now his
rework is like
it's pretty interesting
so he goes into sort of the the sentry
mode but it's only for a limited time
he sends out little bouncing bombs now
his ult is basically sort of like mortar
shells which is quite interesting
by genji you can deflect them can they
projectiles yeah
that's amazing
they'll always be uh that
the bastion ultimate uh at first
everybody thought it was stupidly
overpowered because it fires really fast
so you could drop this on the back line
and just kill the anna kill the zen kill
them kill everyone with it um but as
soon as we realize that anything that
deals with a projectile will stop this
so
defense matrix obviously barriers and
shields but there's not that many in the
game no more thank god for that um or
sigma can eat them again you can deflect
them um oh nice erisa can spear them now
at the sky but it's very interesting uh
kind of reworks and little subtle
changes
um let's talk a little bit about push
i'm on the fence about push
uh it's the new it's a new mode there's
a robot in the middle and uh
as it you know does what it says on the
tin you kind of push it into
one side of the turret of the map and
then you push it into the other side of
the map um by gaining control of it it
definitely feels like
past a certain point there's no turning
back you know like it's pretty much if
you get that robot to a certain point
it's it's pretty much you know game over
there um
i enjoyed it
but do i do i prefer it to like an
escort no i think i think traditional
esc was still probably going to be my
favorite mother what do you two think
this might be a case of because it's a
new thing that we like it more than we
will in a few months time i don't know i
think there might be some balance issues
with this mode i think they might need
to look at the speed the robot runs back
uh to reset because like like you said
and it's rightfully so um we sort of
worked out around 70 to 80 meters if you
pushed it that far
it's pretty difficult to undo all of
that progress like and it doesn't feel
great because you're constantly fighting
against something that you know it's it
literally is an uphill battle and um
i don't know like it
needs a bit of summit
do you know if if it runs back quicker
if you have more players i don't think
it does no
that like that could be a way to not the
backseat design but you know i'm not
sure if it did and then they changed it
because on the ui it does show you the
number of players around the robot so
you think or this is increasing the
speed but i don't think it does um yeah
it does feel like once you
and and you could tell i could tell in
the games that i played once the robot
got to a certain point people you could
visibly see them stop trying as hard
because you're like okay you're now just
farming for kills and you're just trying
to figure out where you know what's
going on with the game as opposed to
trying to genuinely maybe they think
that
sorry time i was going to say the other
thing is like um sometimes it might not
be optimal to actually fight around the
robot
which kind of defeats the point of it
you know yeah it's true um yeah it felt
like
an uphill struggle at certain points and
at that point it was just like counting
down the clock and
i was like man it would be nice if there
was a surrender option
a white flag
and you never want that
yeah i just like there needs to be i
don't care anymore but
i i mean like i do see i do foresee them
well i can imagine they're thinking oh
it is tricky but if you manage to pull
it off imagine how good that's gonna
feel and imagine how hyped that is gonna
be which i understand if and i bet if it
does happen it would be pretty hype is
to watch it happen in your own game or
in an overwatch league thing but the
problem you have is you're more likely
to have people just disengage once they
know that they're their chances of
they need to exponentially improve their
their play skill and their performance
to get to have a chance of clawing it
back i feel like that's asking people to
leak over a bar that's way too high can
almost feel like it's more difficult
than two cp final points and of course
they've removed assault from the game
so
i don't know what's going to happen with
push let's talk about i guess the
elephant in the room is uh from what we
played and like i said we didn't play
any of the pve
um
is this a meaningful enough jump
to call it overwatch too
i think the thing that would have caused
that would have like really justified it
being called overwatch 2 is now not
being released as part of this like the
decoupling of campaign and and i feel
like the campaign was doing
almost all the heavy lifting when it
comes to that two at the end of the year
the end of the title yeah um that's not
to say the stuff that is in the
multiplayer isn't like interesting it's
definitely
is but
it feels like a major not a major it
feels like a mid-sized rework to
multiplayer like a big a big like
content update for multiplayer um you
know we've had equivalent equivalence in
like in the cs days going from 1.5 to
like 1.6 or like
1.6 to you know condition zero or
something like that it feels like that
as opposed to here is source this is a
brand new version of of the game um i
personally don't feel like based on the
alpha that i played the multiplayer
alone is enough for people to be like oh
yeah this is a this is a meaningful
update
yeah i think this is just a commitment
to start updating pvp again that's
literally it do i think there's enough
here to make people happy well i think
there's going to be maybe a bit of
debate around three years for this um
which isn't entirely fair because
okay we know what's going on at blizzard
and we also know that there is um pve in
development so it's not like they've
just been working on pvp
um the way i'm viewing this and this
might be me just drinking the kool-aid
or whatever um
is it it's just a resumption of updates
to the game of which we've not had since
echo and that's it yeah and it's like
hey guys we're gonna start updating the
game again
um you know people still get excited for
new heroes in overwatch it still has got
that special
like draw you know the hero decides they
get unbiased as hell but the hero
designs and even the skins and stuff
when i look at valor and i look at apex
and look at its peers it blows them away
maybe that's me just having you know
i don't know you guys tell me but it
like it always seems to have that i
agree
yeah the thing that will ignite that
kind of love in the same way that we
have in a lot of people is the single
player like i feel like the once the
single player and the multiplayer are
alongside each other i feel like it's
going to be a way more compelling
package because you want you know based
on what we know about the single player
it's more story based it's more mission
based you're going to get a lot more
some of that characterization that we
love you know until now we we played
overwatch multiplayer and then we
watched the shorts and read the comics
and in the early days for a good few
years that was like massive for us it
was incredibly hype we'd read a comic
and be like i really love this character
now and now that has been transferred
into something a little more meaningful
in terms of in terms of gameplay is a
campaign i think that once they have
this pipeline where it's like people
play the campaign there's a great moment
with genji that they experience in the
campaign they're like i just want to
play more genji they jump into the
multiplayer and they're excited about
being genji and deflecting and being
annoying in the back line again and that
kind of stuff so i feel like on its own
the multiplayer feels like 1.5 i feel
like once the the campaign comes in it
will feel more like an overwatch too and
then there will be a better back and
forth between um the kind of the cool
stuff the single player is doing to
enhance and augment the multiplayer we
are by our nature our jobs and our
personalities tinkerers we like to get
in there and figure out what's going on
and figure out the dynamics and
and like i'm excited to jump in i know
that i'll play it for a while my
question is whether it's going to become
an obsession again like whether it's
going to be another four years of being
obsessed by this what would it need to
do to do that for six months
how would you need to change to do that
low time in your yeah i i the thing that
i struggle with right now is there was a
time when overwatch came out and maybe
it was because our understanding of it
was limited but it felt like everything
was meaningful viable and had a place if
you know what i mean yeah um like you
could pick any character and be like
yeah i understand why this character
plays like this and it doesn't feel
broken or like completely out of place
whereas now i feel like partly because
the roster is as big as it is there's
characters that are already being
written off like
winston is basically dead in the water
and i worry about that element of it if
you know what i mean like i i worry that
it's a it's a thing that it's gonna have
very specific ways to enjoy it
like you need to be a good genji player
you need to have um a good ryan on your
team and you need to have this this and
this there's going to be a
my worry is there's a restrictive and
very defined mayor
um that is that is kind of carried on
from the old game as opposed to here's a
brand new
set of tools has a brand new kind of
landscape for you to figure out what's
going on and there's multiple things
that could change it based on what i
played there was not a lot of that if
you know what i mean i wasn't making any
discoveries and that element of
discovery is super important for me i
feel like the community needs kind of a
runway to
define their play styles and figure out
what makes things tick in the game and
without that i feel like they're going
to come in be like that was a nice hit
of nostalgia anyway i'm off to play this
other game
out of out of interest style so what do
you reckon like how do you feel
that same question back at you yeah i
think um launch overwatch you the the
ips totally brand new nobody's got a
clue so everything is full on discovery
mode it's like when you play your first
mmo you know i'll always remember
playing everquest and it's it's amazing
to me but i can never go back to that
but it was amazing yeah overwatch too uh
and this is the thing that's always
perplexed me with it is
um
it's a known quantity what overwatch is
and this isn't a radical change to the
game it's not like
a cast are gone and we've got 30 new
heroes it's not it's okay we've got
minor reworks we've got one new game
mode coming in at the moment hopefully
we get more new game modes in the future
yes we're getting pve at some point um i
think that the issue to me is it's it's
like the cadence at which the content
comes out because i think whenever this
launches
[Music]
it will pull people in but maybe for two
weeks maybe a month and then you're like
well i've played this before so
it's the same that's over to blizzard
then to go no wait a minute we've got
this we've got this we've got this and
it's can they do that and have blizzard
historically been able to do that they
haven't so
i don't know i don't know
um yeah it's interesting it's it's a
very interesting one um
and i guess we'll just have to wait and
see to find out silos thank you so much
for joining us where can people find you
on youtube.com
uh stylosa on all socials and on tick
tock for some get nicked my name it's
stylizer um what
oh wow
oh my god have a word uh with the folks
over at tic toc thank you so much for
watching uh for more on overwatch 2 make
sure to subscribe to the channel we'll
see you next time
[Music]